hi
i'm hannes
and today i'm going to talk to you about
how you can stop punching yourself in
the face
which is like my favorite activity not
punching myself in the face
now the reason i made this talk is
i've been in software teams
for over a decade and a half
and i've seen teams hurt themselves over
and over and over again
in the same way
and it became a pet peeve
for me
and i figured like i'll have to stole
the story to people
so the first thing
that i want to look at is what are we
meant to do
as software developers when we deliver a
software product is we're actually
delivering value
we're helping a business succeed
one of the things i always do i'm a
consultant
and is i try and follow the money it's
like how is this company
making money where is the value where is
our software product
going to make a change
and help this company succeed
and if we try to keep our eyes on the
prize
and we try to keep that into the back of
our heads
a lot of this will come naturally
and for those who were in my talk
yesterday they know that i have a thing
with magpies
now let me tell you about the magpie
gonna tell you about two creatures the
magpie is a bird
it's black and white
it has a pretty long tail
it grows up to about half a meter long
and it has a wing span of up to 60
centimeters
they're omnivores
they're pretty intelligent
and they're rumored to be attracted to
shiny tanks
right
you've all heard this myth right the
bird that steals the jewelry
now the second creature that i want to
talk about is the software developer you
should all be familiar with that
creature
they're human they might be black might
be white
they don't have a tail
they grow up to about 2 meters 20.
they don't have wings but they're also
omnivores they're also pretty
intelligent
and they're also attracted to shiny
in this case they're attracted to
libraries and frameworks and
architecture but it's always like ooh
shiny i want that
now we have to wonder ourselves
is that so strange
is it still so strange that us software
software developers are attracted to all
those shiny things
i don't think it is
i mean software development is still a
very very young profession
unlike woodworking which i do as a hobby
in woodworking they found out a long
time ago how to use a
chisel without splitting the wood
they found out a lot of techniques that
have been used for decades if not
centuries and they are like a guaranteed
way to success
but because our profession is so young
relatively
we are still finding out which
the surefire ways to success are
and actually there are none
and because of that everything is
changing
libraries that are relevant today might
not be in two or three or five years if
you're in the javascript world they
might not be relevant tomorrow
but still knowing all this you got into
this profession regardless of this
knowledge it's like i'm gonna have to
figure stuff out on my own
that sounds like a cool job
so is it weird that you're attracted to
all these shiny libraries
no i don't think so
second problem is our education
and i like to compare
the state of
i.t educations like software engineering
to building houses
and if you go to college what you would
get by comparison is you would get a
course in
they'll teach you how to build a wall
and your practice to build like two
meter wide walls
that's that's the thing you're gonna
learn
and then we're gonna teach you a class
in in tiling
kitchen walls
so you do some tiling
and there will be a theoretical course
maybe about roof construction it's like
how can we do the beams for a wood uh a
roof so that it doesn't collapse
of course you'll get a course in
electrical wiring
and they'll teach you how to do some
pipes
right and this is the knowledge that
they send you off into the field with
but instead of asking you to do any of
these things
what they tell you to
is can you like design and build an
entire house
because that's the job that they usually
stow upon us as software developers
they ask us to do the whole job end to
end
do the architecture build it deploy it
run it everything
but those are the only skills you got
so we need to look for guidance
and we do what
everyone would do is we look at people
who are successful
so we come to conferences like this one
and you listen to people like me and we
tell you what to do right
and that's pretty cool you also go on
the internet and you'll need you'll read
some blog posts or you'll look at some
videos or
you'll try and gather knowledge
and the natural thing is to look at the
big companies that are succeeding it's
like how are they doing it
how are they getting to the end and
in their software delivery
and we look at all these things and we
do
as these do
and i have some rare footage
of a software developer that tried to
implement kubernetes in his company
and he ran into the wall
and i'm sure that a lot of you have felt
this feeling that at some points during
your career you run into a wall
and you wonder why
why did you run into that wall what
happened what did we do wrong
and for that you're gonna have to join
me on a
journey with chat i googled chat
i got this gif
um
any resemblance between chad and any
person that you know or that i might
know
is merely coincidental okay this is
these are not true stories
so i have six stories and then i'll wrap
things up and the first one is about
ravendb
now
i was in a team with chad
and
we had this application
this application processed text files
the text files came in through an api
and they needed to get processed and
what our product already did it
extracted about 70 of the data that we
needed from those text files and it
dumped that into a database for the
online system
but at some point the product manager
comes to us and he says yeah
i think the other 30
might be valuable in the future
so is there a way that we can maybe
store those text files for later usage
so that if we ever decide that we want
to do something with those 30 percent
extra data
we can actually get it
so up comes chat and
you have to know chad is one of these
guys he reads all the blog posts he goes
to the conferences and he's like oh
i've learned about this great new
technology it's called ravendb
it's a document database it's really
fast and what we can do is we can
actually parse those text files
and dump them into ravendb
so that in the future if we need to
query the data we can just get it
so yeah that's what chat did
now
the problem is
he started
doing this
and
he set up a vm he installed ravendb on
it he built the whole system like
parsing the text files dumping it into
ravendb it took him quite a bit of time
but what we learned really quickly is
that the price per gigabyte of something
like ravendb is extremely high
you have licensing costs you have to
maintain your operating system you have
to maintain the database engine i mean
it adds up
and because of all the moving parts and
it was the first time that he actually
did anything real with raven db it took
a lot of time as well
and the biggest problem was whenever the
structure of our text files changed
his system broke because it was actually
parsing the contents and like putting it
into documents
so what chad forgot here
is to check if this technology was a
technical fit to his problem
can is it suitable to solve the problem
that we are having
so the questions that you should ask
yourself are these it's like are we not
trying to put the square block in the
round hole
are we not trying to use this technology
to add it to our cv
is it actually solving a problem that
we're having right now
and you might want to compare it to
other competing technologies to see if
you can find a better fit you will have
to wonder like is this going to help us
or is it going to cost extra time what
are the costs that are implied with this
solution
and what are the extra maintenance costs
because that's something us developers
tend to forget we look at the shiny we
got the thing up and running but all the
costs that will come down with it down
the line we forget about those right
that's not our problem
well it usually becomes our problem
so where did chad go wrong here is he
forgot to consider that ravendb is
actually a database and the database is
meant to be queried and ravendb is very
powerful it has indexing it has
projected views it it's a very very
powerful thing to use
but if you only use it to store stuff
it's going to be extremely expensive so
what could he have done
is used something else where he didn't
have to parse the text files
and where he could just dump them into
something where he could retrieve them
for later use
something like
amazon
s3 or azure blob storage that would be
perfect fits for this scenario
you dump your text files in there done
you don't need to parse them price per
gigabyte is extremely low
if you want to have your data globally
redundant i mean it doesn't really add
that much to the cost
and you don't have to maintain it amazon
or microsoft will do that for you
so that day we learn well in that in
that project chad and i we learned about
technical fit
so we took that into our careers for the
next story
i was working with chat
and we were brought in
to a customer
and they had an asp.net
mvc web application it was in the mvc
four times might might have been mvc5
but like still full framework
and a lot of this application had been
written by
uh near shore contractors i'm not gonna
name the country
um
and they brought us in because
performance was horrible
so we started looking at what was
actually happening in the code base and
we were profiling this
by the way this was 2014 this becomes
relevant to the story in a minute
and basically what we saw there's that
the
objects that were selected through the
orm they lived all the way until the
presentation logic
which meant that if they were building
their menu for instance they were not
just triggering an n plus one select it
was like an n times m plus one select it
was like horrible
menu loaded 2000 queries to the database
no wonder it was slow right
so we figured like the the easiest path
forward is if we cut like somewhere in
the middle
it's like let's shield the business
logic from the presentation part and
make sure that that is a hard boundary
where we cannot have this kind of
shenanigans again
so that's what we set out to do
and chad had an idea he had worked with
agata on a previous project
and for those of you who don't know
agata it is basically a request response
library on top of wcf
yeah i'm i'm that old sorry
um
so we started to check if this would
actually help and it would solve our
issue because it was a boundary inside
the whole process of retrieving data
from the database
but the cool thing is that we could
either run it in process which didn't
cause any overhead for us at the time we
could still still keep the same
deployments but if we wanted to we could
actually move it to work over wcf over
the network and then separate it into
two different servers which was
attractive it's like it's a good plan to
have for the future but we don't have to
invest right now so that was good
so it's definitely a technical fit for
the problem that we were having
can you guess what went wrong
any of you know i got that by the way
no okay what we're wrong is this
chad had forgotten to check on github
and akata was mainly maintained by one
person davey bryan
and at some point around 2013
remember we did our project 2014.
davey fergus
lost interest in
agata or disappeared of the face of the
earth i don't know what happened
but basically this library was no longer
maintained
but this was also the time that async
weight became really big in the net
world that was like the time that that
was starting to happen
but right after the out of the box after
we had implemented agata in our code
base and we wanted to switch to a new
framework a new version of the framework
where we could actually use a single
weight we found out like oh agatha
doesn't have support for the sync away
so instead of
having something that really helped us
the thing that we put into our code base
became a liability because it wasn't
being maintained which meant that we
either had to fork it and maintain it
ourselves or switch to something else
and invest the same effort all over
again
and that's no fun
so what the chat forgets is he forgot to
check for a warning site signs
warning sciences
can this technology become a risk for us
and of course we don't have a crystal
ball to look into the future
but there is some stuff that you can
check it's like who maintains this
project
are they still actively working on this
are they still blogging about it
because if they're not no longer
blogging about and they're blogging
about other stuff it means that they
might lose interest and they might be
working on something else
the source code available how is it
licensed i mean if it's something really
really critical to the thing that you're
doing you might want to
maintain it yourself but at least you
would have to be able to so the
licensing model should allow you to make
a fork and maintain it yourself
and you should be able to get the source
and when companies get bought by other
companies that's also usually a moment
that licensing models change and that's
a huge risk
now what chad could have done
is used mediator
because mediator does basically the same
thing as agata but it was actively
maintained by more than one person it's
mainly jimmy who does it
but it's still
something that
could have given us all the benefits of
agata
without the risk of using something that
wasn't actively maintained anymore
it was also open source under the apache
license so
if jimmy were to die
we could actually
take a road forward and use that
so
when you know about technical fit and
you're checking for warning signs signs
not much else can go wrong right
well you know that there's four more
stories coming so you know what the
answer to that is
on one of the next projects that i was
on with chad
um
we were faced with
a situation like this
it was basically um mostly a crud
application
built on a proper solid dependency
injection stack i think this was
probably around 2016.
it was used built using asp.net mvc used
sql server there was a bus architecture
that allowed our software product to
talk to other products inside the
company and this it was actually it was
pretty well built um developers were not
struggling to deliver features it was
okay
and then the task came it's like okay we
want to have a screen where you can edit
some data but what we basically also
want to see is the entire audit trail
who edited the data who did what to it
what is going to happen
and
it was just one screen but chat like
being the responsible developer he said
okay but i have a solution that is like
a great technical fit
and that is also that doesn't have any
warning signs it's very actively
maintained
so he came up with event store
chad had become a really big fan of of
greg young around that time and about
all the cqrs stuff that he was speaking
about and inevitably he came into
contact with event store
and it's perfect i mean if you want to
project an audit trail and show it in a
screen event store is something that can
really help you with that
and it was being actively maintained so
technical fit warning signs all good
so what went wrong
well chad started implementing this
and he built that screen and he used
event store and it all ran really well
but let me tell you about the team that
we were in we had some remote
contractors in another country
and there were quite a bit of juniors in
the team
and none of them had event store
knowledge
but chad worked on that feature on his
own and he delivered it and it was
glorious i mean it worked really well
and he used event store in the proper
way
what he forgot
was to teach the others about it
and the result was that none of them
actually touched any of the event store
stuff so if anything needed to happen in
an event store screen the only guy who
was doing it was chad
so
when chad was the only one working on
that that became a bottleneck if chad
was absent when he went on holiday that
was like a period that we could not
deliver anything on the event store
screens
which is sad and it became a risk and it
became a problem we eventually got the
whole team on board
but team skills
are
not optional
i'm not saying that you have to teach
everyone but at least you have to be
able to deliver because if you give the
business this nice screen where they can
see the audit trail
you can be sure that if they're
demanding new features this is something
they're gonna want everywhere right so
you'll build more and more and more
screens just like that
and building skills take time takes time
i mean nobody flips a baseball bat like
that without like hours and hours and
hours of practice
so when you bring something new on board
in your team you have to wonder how much
is it gonna cost to get everybody up to
speed on this
do we already have the knowledge good if
we don't like how do we build it is the
knowledge available is there
documentation do we have to write our
own documentation do we
have to write the code together i don't
know
figure out what you need and how much it
is going to cost to build that knowledge
inside your team so that this technology
will not become a bottleneck in the
future
and there's a couple of really good ways
of doing this i find pair programming or
programming an excellent way to spread
knowledge
if you build something together
not only are you building
the thing with more than one person
usually of higher quality you're also
spreading the knowledge
everybody's knowledge goes into the same
thing and that is a glorious way to do
it
but there's also other things you can go
and follow a course somewhere you can
look up videos online you can build your
own documentation
and you can help people with their first
steps when they're using this new thing
that you're trying to bring on board
so when the team is up to speed
and we're choosing the right
technologies or life console becomes
already a lot easier
but then something else happened
same project
but
chad comes to me
one day in the morning before all the
others arrives
and he says
honest we need to talk
we need to stop using energy framework
for those who are not in the net world
the entity framework is our orm of
choice it maps between objects in the
database
so okay
i'm intrigued
because as i said earlier the
application was mainly corrupt
and an orm is a perfect fit for those
kinds of applications it was like why
so i asked him like what are your
frustrations why why are you telling me
that we
shouldn't be
using entity framework anymore
it tells me i mean it's very very slow
and it does so so many different things
i mean and we're only using it to query
and to update data i mean
we don't need all of this
we have no control over the sql that it
outputs
the sequel looks very messy i mean the
screenshot on the right is is an actual
screenshot of um to be fair of an older
version of entity framework um
and all of these arguments are true
in the correct context
but while this sql actually looks messy
sql server doesn't really have a problem
with it it's properly written it's it's
not like it's really slow sql it just
doesn't look easy on the eyes for us as
developers
so i'm wondering like what's happening
here why does he want to move away from
this
so i sat down it's like can you show me
some of the problems that you have
and
the things that were actually going on
there with chad
is first of all he was hitting a lot of
db context initialization problems
for those of you who have worked with
nad framework they will know the first
time you create a database context of a
certain time
entity framework needs to build its
mental model it needs to learn about
what do the tables look like in the
database what do the classes look like
in code and how do i map between those
in the old days that used to be all in a
huge xml file that caused like countless
merge problems it was the edmx file who
did edmx at some point
yeah no fun isn't it
um
but even if you use code first enemy
framework needs to build its mental
model and that takes time
and from the second tb context that you
make of the same time it's actually snap
fast but why does it feel so it felt so
slow for for chad is when he was coding
he was running from his ide which meant
he restarted the process every time
and he would hit that db context
initialization every time and his
conclusion would be like oh this is very
slow
look i did my first request took 600
milliseconds that's not acceptable
did the same request again
33 milliseconds yeah
so once i explained this oh okay
but there's there's other problems
i mean look at this this one this one is
slow consistently
and what was happening there was he had
written an n plus one select
and m plus one selections are where you
select n records and then inevitably by
accident trigger an extra query for each
record that you're looping over
it was usually at those times um
lazy loading was the default so if you
forgot to fetch the dependent entity
and you accessed it entity framework
would be a nice guy and fetch it for you
but it meant a lot of round trips to the
database
so if your api call goes to the database
a couple hundred maybe a couple of
thousand times there's no way you're
going to get like
sub 100 millisecond performance
so we looked at that
by opening a profiler it's like what's
actually happening here oh you're
triggering lots of queries
so if you just include that entity and
eager load it on your first fetch
that actually solves it
and suddenly the api call becomes fast
and then there was one missing database
index on a large table i mean that's not
an entity framework problem but it's
something that the profiler
and the sql server
performance analyzer will actually help
you with
so we put an index on that on that field
and it actually helped the query
immensely
and then there was the last thing is
like there was one place where he was
actually fetching the entire entity and
he only needed a couple of fields
now it was an entity that had 200
columns um
don't ask me how we got there
um
but by writing a project a projection we
didn't fetch all the huge because there
were a couple of blob fields in there we
didn't fetch all the things we just
fetched the fields that we need and also
that became fast
and after i sat down with chad
and we talked about these things
it became clear to me like until that
day
for chad entity framework had been magic
and what i always encourage developers
to do i coach a lot of young developers
fresh out of college at the company that
i work for
i always tell them to take away the
magic
try to understand how the thing that
you're using was built
because if you do that
as it worked for chat actually after we
sat down and looked at all those
problems chad became like the go-to guy
in the team on entity framework he
became actually he became a big fan
but when you take away the magic it
becomes a lot less likely that you're
going to abuse the technology and use it
in the wrong way i'm not saying that you
have to
build your own don't do that like
there's
for most of the things that we do
there's people smarter than us who have
already done it for us so
don't do that
but try to understand what they had to
use to actually build this technology
that you're going to use
try and maybe write one of the features
or try and look at the source like do
you understand how this thing was
constructed
and if you do that
it becomes a lot easier to derive the
proper way of using a certain technology
if it's no longer magic to you you're
gonna do a good job using it
so at this point we are we feel really
skilled and we move on to a new customer
and we arrive
at a team
and chad does this amazing job it was a
huge code base it had to be going on for
eight years um
and the chat that i worked with on that
on that project he was a hero i mean he
was the superhero
on the of the team
he was the lead developer
and the whole team really admired his
skill
he was basically the only one that spent
his free time learning new stuff but he
always brought it back to the others and
he liked really he really liked doing
things the right way
and he took care of the team skills part
when he learned something new
a new framework an awesome library i
don't know um he explained it to them he
gave a presentation about what is this
technology how does it work how was it
built what are the tips and tricks when
you're using it he built um on our
confluence he built a documentation page
about like the do's and don'ts
and he got everybody on board
and when chad did that the whole team
looked up and was like okay yes that is
a better way of doing things let's do it
like that from now on
and they would do that
but what went wrong in this project
because even though he took care of of
technical fit and and he checked for
warning signs and he got everybody up to
speed and he took away the magic for
everyone it still went wrong
otherwise it wouldn't be telling you the
story right
the problem was that all of the old code
remained written in the old way
so we had a code base
where you could basically date features
by looking at what practices and
technologies were used it's like oh this
front end is using angular not angularjs
um and it is doing dependency injection
in the background it's using that
version of this and that oh that must
have been written around 2017
probably spring 2017 right that was the
code base that we had it's like age
rings in a tree trunk you could date it
and that became a huge problem
because after those eight years
and chad doing this great job the whole
time
we had
four different ways of doing front end
code
and three different ways of doing
back-end code we had two api frameworks
we had two database engines
and we had three different
ways of structuring
the code
what i'm trying to say is if you do that
it becomes extremely hard to onboard new
people on your team training a new
developer on that team typically took
three to five months depending on the
skill of the developer
but three to five months is a very very
long time for somebody to be productive
because if you have a little bit of
turnover on your on your team that means
that your existing team members are also
spending time for those three to five
months on training the new person
so what you have to worry about is like
if we bring in new stuff we have to
maybe think about what we can throw away
what problem are we trying to solve with
this new technology and do we really
need to bring it in
maybe do we have an old thing that is
similar that we can throw out now that
would be really good
and how much effort would it be
to actually throw that out because that
is the hard part you're gonna have to
explain to the business that you're
gonna invest a lot of time
in code that you already had and that
already worked
and to the business that feels like
throwing away money
but it's the only way that you can
actually keep
moving forward at a consistent pace with
a team for an extended period of time
so spending that money money
or that time is not optional
so make it very clear to them what the
cost is of keeping both like keeping the
old code as it is
and the new code that you're writing
with the new thing it's like we're gonna
have this new functionality on the new
features but the cost is that we have to
maintain it every new developer that we
train it's gonna cost us two weeks extra
all of this stuff you have to
make sure that is clear to them so that
it doesn't become a choice
so that it's the only way of doing
things is if we bring in something new
replace something old
what i would want to see is that you all
build hollow trunks like this one
take away the old code and migrate it to
the new way of doing things
and for instance if you look at front
end frameworks and you switch from one
one to the other
it's not really that bad if there is
like a transfer period where you're
doing both
but don't bring in a turret before you
finish migrating from the first right
so estimate all of that
and then there's the worst thing that we
developers do to hurt ourselves
like really badly
um
the case that we were on
was a greenfield project and as every
developer stream like oh we finally get
to do the chance to do things right
we can pick the proper technologies we
can do the right thing
and it was a small line of business
application wasn't really that complex
so we figured yeah we can try the new
stuff stuff here the team was
one senior developer
and three deaths that had some skills
they had a little bit of experience but
none of them more than three
years what is really relevant is the
team didn't really have any experience
in running their own in production
all they did before this was just code
and deliver it to the ops team
but because they got this chance to do
things right and and the business one
was on board
the stack that they picked was they
chose to do an angular front-end they
chose to do identity server for their uh
authentication and authorization
they chose to do docker and kubernetes
you remember
the guy jumping into into the wall right
they were going to do everything
microservices they were going to use a
document database in the in the back end
and all of this was new
i mean
that by itself is a
massive
team skills violation right
so the team got stuck
they really got stuck on learning the
new stack and they really got stuck on
handling deploying stuff to production
and actually delivering anything
but a lot of things became harder
because all of these things were
separate services they struggled with
monitoring with logging with debugging
and they struggled with the proper use
of mongodb because they had had been
used to having
relational databases where all of the
data could be queried in different
patterns
and that was suddenly you had to think
about how you were going to query it up
front when you construct your documents
that project got a huge delay
because of that team skills violation
but there's something else that happened
there it was also massively over
engineered for what it was supposed to
do so team skills
my opinion on that
is when you bring in new stuff do it one
and one at a time
and if possible if possible at all
try to avoid
the pressure to deliver functionality
with the pressure of learning
uh something else
something new
because if you combine those two
they will both affect each other the
time that you spend on learning is going
to affect your ability to deliver
so when you learn something new i'm not
saying that you shouldn't
but budget the time for it do it
properly
do them one at a time
and explain this risk to your business
owner
i've heard people say things like this
a lot of times
and it always turned out to be a lie
it's like when we do this new thing
we're going to be able to deliver it so
much faster and so much better
yeah right after you've learned it true
but not now
but the thing that really went wrong
there is they
took an architecture
that would have been
suitable if you have the problem set of
maybe netflix
but it was a small internally used line
of business application
and the architecture
you could write that application that
way but the architecture really didn't
help them it got in their way
and this is something we do too often we
look at those big companies we look at
how they are successful
and we think that their solutions will
also apply to us
but we forget that
they developed their way of working
just because they had a whole bunch of
issues along along the way
and if you go back and you look at
netflix's first presentations about
doing microservices
you actually can find some talks where
people are really honest about this it's
like yeah we have this to solve that
problem but now we have a whole bunch of
new problems so we had to build tooling
for that
and maybe a lot of that tooling has been
commoditized over the last couple of
years but if you want to do proper micro
services you're gonna bring in a lot of
different things
if you want to be able to properly trace
things authenticate
people
in your system throughout the services
if you want to look at like how stuff
goes wrong and how to debug it and how
to set it up on your local development
machine i mean it's not trivial
i've heard people throw
around the number this was a couple of
years ago that you would need a team for
nine months
and probably around a million euros
before you would actually be able to
deliver any features if you were doing
proper micro services
now because a lot of the stuff has been
combatized since then
we can maybe half the number
it's not magically going to be 50 000
euros
it's gonna cost you a lot of time and
money to get up to speed
so what we should learn from netflix is
not their solution
we should learn about their process of
how they got to this point
and when they started out they didn't
have a complex architecture they started
with something simple and keep it as
simple as you can
start with the simplest thing that you
can start with if we would have done
that greenfield application
just built a simple monolith
maybe learned angular or mongodb like
pick one new thing right we probably
would have delivered it semi on time
but what we would have done is we would
have applied a lot of our skills pushed
it out to production actually delivered
value
and the most valuable thing is if you
push something out you'll learn
you'll learn how your users are going to
use it because that's also something
that we as software developers tend to
do is we over engineer
it's how our mind works
we try and foresee problems that we
might have in the future
a typical one is scaling we always think
that the product is going to be way
bigger than it actually is right
so we already do stuff to
make sure that we will be able to deal
with it when it comes to that point
except usually it turns out that that's
it's another component than the one that
we foresaw that actually needs scaling
so you optimize for the wrong thing
and when you push it out with a simple
solution and you learn about it i'm a
huge fan of instrumenting everything we
push out
not just like logging and monitoring and
which api calls are being used like
which buttons are users actually
pressing
i've heard a talk once about a company
where
their idea for a new feature would
always result in them putting a button
in the ui that didn't do anything
it's like let's see if users actually
press this and they would log that
and it went gracefully i mean when the
user pressed it it would pop up a
message like oh i'm sorry this feature
is not available
but they would know
and the button that got pressed a lot is
like oh this is next thing that we're
going to build i really love that
approach i mean you're building what
people actually want
but you can do the same thing with your
architecture
you push it out and you see what is
being used
just have enough of a design to be able
to deliver value
and then iterate on that design i'm not
saying don't do any architecture i mean
architecture is important and it has to
support your ability to deliver value to
the business
but you should just have enough to move
forward
and then you learn and you iterate
so microservices is a very popular one
and i see so many teams doing
microservices because they feel that
this is proper way of doing things
and there's this image from martin
fowler and you see like i'm standing way
below the line there
the
microservices
there's a couple of real reasons why you
would need them
the first is scaling
if you need to scale
certain parts of your software product
and i'm not even saying that it's only
scaling the production performance it
can also be about scaling teams at
different rates right
but if you need to scale different parts
of your software in in certain ways and
you have to do it differently then
having separate services is a huge
benefit
it's a balance of cost
versus speed versus delivery
when you build a software product that
needs to support multiple clients where
all the clients have different features
and you can enable disable them and
maybe replace them
that is also a very good technical
reason to have different
different services
if different parts of your solution
require different technology stacks
that's also a very good reason to have
different services
and if you have conflicted uh
dependencies in your product where part
a requires version x and
another part
requires version y
that usually doesn't fly in the same
process with most programming languages
so that's also a very good reason
all this we need to scale in the future
stuff i mean that's something future you
can solve
that today's you doesn't have to solve
that problem
so if chat would have done the simple
thing
maybe learned angular
but didn't do microservice i'm pretty
sure
that he would have pushed out that
project on time
and you can already prepare your code
for splitting up splitting off services
basically you can already provide the
dotted line like cut here cut out this
part in the future if you need to scale
it independently
i have a whole talk about
building
plugins and doing that in process as a
way of keeping vertical slices inside
your
inside your code base
but you still deploy it as one monolith
which makes it a lot easier to manage in
in a whole bunch of ways
so that's probably what chat should have
done and he would have been able to
deliver that value that we are so after
so that's the end of the six stories
um
i want you to remember the six
conclusions
first check
if the thing that you're going to use is
a technical fit to the problem that
you're going to solve
is it going to help you
and then check
if it's something that become a risk at
short term there's a whole bunch of
things that you can check
if packages are critical for your
software system it's okay to read the
blog posts of the person who are
actually building this
you're actually doing your job
then get
enough people on board
to be able to use this and to not become
a risk and a bottleneck on one person
and make sure that none of it is magic
to you take away the magic make sure
that you know how it was built so that
you use it properly
take out the old stuff make sure that
you're able to onboard people make sure
that people can reason about the code
base it's very important
and let your architecture solve your
problems and not be the cause of it it
should not be the cause of your misery
it should actually be a solution to
something that you actually run into
and after telling you all this you're
probably wondering like who was this
chad guy right who are we blaming here
and
in some of these stories chad was me
um or it was the whole team or somebody
else on the team that i was on or i
totally make made him up to drive home
the story
but you might have noticed that i've
written chad in all caps on all the
slides it's because actually it's an
acronym
it's a carelessly or helplessly acting
developer
and
in none of these stories
chad did edit anything wrong on purpose
he was always acting
with the best interest of the team at
heart he was trying to help
but because he didn't really know
how to do it in the correct way
he ended up shooting in his own foot
so we have to wonder if we are we don't
want to be chats what do we want to be
wouldn't it be better to be rad
right not rapid application development
no
responsibly acting developers
well today you can
if you're on board with my mission
you can help me spread the word about
this
so you can follow red certification on
twitter i made a certification program
where you can become a certified rat
developer okay you can follow us on
twitter
or you can go on redshirt.com and take a
quiz it's 10 questions and after you've
seen today's talk it should be trivial
and you can become rad certified
and i have these certification kits
unfortunately they didn't make it with
me from belgium um but what i'll do is
for the first first 30 people who show
me that they got certified today
um i'll actually send you one of these
certification kits in the mail
and if you have a target with your
manager that you still have to get a
certificate this year i mean this is a
really easy way to do it and the year is
only going to be like one more month so
if that is in your targets like get it
out of the way today
my name is hannes i am the head of
learning and development at a company
called access in belgium this is my
twitter handle and for those who were
here yesterday my icq number i'm trying
to make icq great again
i have three kids um i'm an amateur
guitar builder and i'm a lego enthusiast
um
we have 10 more minutes for questions so
i'll be happy to take any questions you
might have
okay you all want coffee i understand
um if you should have any questions
throughout the day i'll be running
around so come and talk to me if you
show me that you're certified fine i'll
take your address and i'll send you a
certification kit
have a nice rest of your conference and
have a great day
oh one more thing one more thing
can i maybe promote tonight's after
party um a bunch of us are going to do
funny talks where we uh try to make
developers laugh and then after that we
will actually play some music tonight on
stage here downstairs so make sure you
don't miss it it's going to be great fun
bye see you tonight
you